每次講到關鍵分點
小哥就不能說 不能說 不能說
今天一定要說
10年來
對
區間獲利前15名
第一名賺6億
不要洩漏出來
地緣分點大勝八國聯軍
對
20分鐘
中午出來吃個飯下個單也不為過
對
入港的分點怎麼都在買股票
高手高高手
勝率最高的股票
地緣大買
股價又在地板下
我們叫雙地概念股
雙地概念股
厲害啦
公司賣發力公自己偷偷買
嗨
你還記得上次啊
我有穿這個顏色的衣服
是我們兩個人
沒錯啊
那天發生什麼事
大碟
你是不是因為大盤大碟
就說我要換綠色衣服是不是
我跟你講一個最可怕的事情
真的非常可怕
我發現我們全東森
最會做股票的人就藏在更衣室
為什麼
因為我們衣服都是先配好的
先配好的
先配好的 給你看證明
你看喔 這是更衣室主管賣給我的
你看這一件 你看時間
你可以唸一下
9月22號17點19分
是不是
他先配好了
今天9月24號跌300點
是不是
他那天就配好了
然後我還跟他說
不是 姐是做股市節目
你配這個給我幹嘛呢
今天立刻就從衣櫃拿出來
就這件 就這件
那下次LINE給我一下
好 我要去買葡萄
買普特買好買滿
而且上一次跌600多點那一次
也是先配好的
太神了
因為不可能當天才配
他一定前提幫你選
對 對 對
太厲害了
所以這種一定有地緣性
我們就跟著他就好
他貴姓 他是哪個媽媽
他是女生喔
叫愛麗絲 愛麗絲媽媽
對
因為現在這個
我們做股票的都要叫媽媽
為什麼
這個股市呢
以前喊牌是在電視喊
對
現在都在爆料同學會喊
爆料同學會現在前幾名的都是媽媽
都是媽媽
對
你咧
我要改名 我要叫全正媽媽
你叫小哥媽媽
小哥媽媽
對啊
因為小哥喊牌沒有用
叫媽媽喊牌比較有用
所以你今天來
你就必須拿出看家本領了
你就被逼到
被這些媽媽逼到
對 我們不講信仰的
對
那些媽媽在散物心目中
她不是媽媽 她是媽祖
你要給那些媽媽一些顏色看看
不敢 不敢
我們不能給地方媽媽顏色看看
不請
好 很久違囉
歌有仇必報
我們還記得這個單元嗎
因為後來我們改成電視網路跨影版之後
小歌常常都是跟另外一位搭配
我們來交出不同的火花
就是籌碼面有時候跟基本面互打
但很多人都敲碗說
那我們光是講歌的籌碼
怎麼很久沒有單獨做了
今天就給你滿滿的小哥喔
而且還記得嗎
之前我們講籌碼的時候
每次講到關鍵分點
小哥就不能說不能說不能說
今天一定要說
因為很多媽媽現在來勢洶洶
都比小哥厲害喔
所以小哥現在要拿出一點
好不好
真材實料
之前也是啦
但今天要拿出不傳之秘
對 不傳之秘
好
因為今天講的
不只是關鍵分點對不對
他真的是地方媽媽咧
嗯 對 都在地人
在地人 在地人
在地人怎麼厲害吧
他們都低買高賣
怎麼可能
低買高賣
我們這樣講
這個我心目中
做股票最厲害的
第一個 有緣人
有緣人 有緣的
真的喔 佛心做法就對了
有緣就會做到
有緣就看你跟老闆有沒有緣
哦 不容易
對 有緣人
跟老闆很有緣的
你就会买在低点
跟老板没有缘的
你会被老板出货
这个缘分在前世
就要修五百世
不知道是因缘还是孽缘
好 第一个缘人
第二个呢 主力
主力还排在有缘人的下面
没错
老板是先知道的
那老板也有可能
到货给主力
我们也待会跟各位讲的案例
这老板是倒给主力的
所以就是一个心狠手辣的老板
沒錯 厲害的老闆
第三名我認為投信
投信排在中間
因為投信他們至少有研究
可能比主力再弱一點
有時候被主力出國
沒錯
第四名外資
外資大漏腳
外資好慘
馬卡
就不管我們哪一個來賓來
都講外資實在是點點點
只有穆華哥 最高殺低
穆華哥還蠻喜歡外資的
所以各位記得外資是漏腳
好
你假如認識的人他都在追外資
他可能也是肉腳
哎呦
所以你要搞清楚
研究外資的人可能就是肉腳
那我認識的外資呢
都是肉腳
你認識外資的
外資呢 因為這樣講
他們可能股票賠錢
期貨賺錢
所以他的股票部分
常常都是肉腳
好 再來最後
就我們可憐的散戶小韭菜啦
對啊 散戶很奇怪
散戶我們常常發現
散戶的宿命
股票呢 從一塊漲到70塊
他不會買
對
從70塊跌到50塊
哇塞 打7折進去買
可是我們有一段時間
也不要忘了
今年就是我們三四月崩跌之後
有一段時間散戶可是很厲害
所以最近的話
要看有緣人的動作
因為現在台股操作的難度
其實變高了 對
我們現在做股票都紅綠配
紅綠配啊
對 就是
要做一些多方的標的
也要做空方的標的
這樣子大點都不用怕
我拍這張的時候
應該股市蠻好的
現在已經變這樣了
因為公司有利多
誰最近知道呢
舉例來說
理財達人秀
做太好了
做到要上市了
你怎麼知道
這就是有一個計畫
這要上市
正在公發
我可以認股嗎
可以沒問題
我可以認股
以後營收噴發的時候
我就第一個知道囉
你是股東
然後你才會盡心盡力
也可以
那這個理財人就有利多
誰稅先知道呢
就這三個
製作人 主持人 對不對
站錢分點 當然我先啊
你是站錢分點
然後我在交代啊 對不對
管錢分點
這個帥哥是台北分點
再交代他 一個交代一個下去
所以他們會先買 對
先買之後呢 股票就上漲
我先買 然後他再買
他再買 我再出
你要記得 很好的循環
發布利多的時候出
讓韭菜進來買
所以呢 誰最先知道
其實就是關鍵核心人物最知道
關鍵核心人物 對
好 接下來說我們看維生
維生呢 這個 我們來看一下
這個關鍵分點
在低檔 它會大買
好 那外資投信呢 它會賣
這邊是分點進出
這邊大買
好 大買
然後外資投信呢 它會賣低點
喔 這邊投信在賣
對 外資在賣
那高檔呢 高檔在幹嘛
高檔外資在賣 投信在賣
那關鍵分點其實都在這邊
都在出貨了 陸續賣出
陸續賣出 對
所以維生呢
就是你要看關鍵分點
好 維生這家公司
其實應該不只維生吧
應該很多公司
都要看關鍵分點
這個我大概統計了200多家
都是關鍵分點比外資厲害
都第一買高賣
然後每天就研究這些分點在幹嘛
可是小哥你過去都不肯告訴我們
誰是關鍵分點
那你今天為什麼願意講
我這個昨天做講義
還特別跟製作人講
不要洩漏出來
他今天洩漏出來
跟人家說不行不行
貼起來貼起來
這什麼這什麼
為什麼要貼起來啊
這個張圖我們只要跟各位講
哎哎哎哎
股價低檔的時候
地緣分點大買
地緣是啊
公司在這裡啊
對 維生
股價低檔的時候
全台灣900多個分點
對
900多個
15名內有8個分點在這裡買
8個跟維生很相關的
一元性很近的在這邊買
維生在鹿港
鹿港有一個工業區很厲害
很多汽車相關的都在這邊所以這個裡面工作的人裡面工作的人可能就在鹿港開戶當然 因為它也是一個小鎮你怎麼跑太遠
對啊 然後發現
這去做好累啊
那這個做好累
公司怎麼賺那麼多
對 趕快買股票
股價也低一點
對 所以發現鹿港的分點
怎麼都在買股票
所以鹿港很厲害啊
之前不是有首歌叫
台北不是我的家嗎
對
因為就在鹿港買股票就好
哎呀 泄露年齡了
我是聽那首歌長大了
好啦 那這個不只公司的人
在那邊賣晚餐的 賣自助餐的
賣蚵仔麵刷的啦
這家公司最近晚上都加班熬夜
燈火通明
在附近賣香腸 賣椒葉
半夜11點叫香腸UberEater
扶胖的叫過去
我很忙 對不對
一去那邊 哇塞停車場滿滿的
趕快買股票
對 他們就先知道
對
那這個在彰化賺錢了
要去台中幹嘛
消費
自殘 買房子
你自殘算不錯
台中可以消費的東西挺多的
對啊
我們常常發現
這個彰化的公司的關鍵分點
常常都在台中
對啊 因為都賺錢都跑到那邊買房子
昨天同學還跟我說什麼
金錢報已經過時了
現在什麼海棋海拔
都聽不懂
沒聽過
我是真的沒聽過
晚上我都回家研究籌碼的
好
所以這邊呢
我們其實有列出來大家參考
就是很多鹿港彰化的分點在賣
鹿港彰化
你看鹿港台中
鹿港台中
都在地分點
在地分點
那這些分點呢
我們做個統計喔
買歸買利不厲害
利不厲害
對
我做統計呢
我是做2500天的統計
也就是說從台股有籌碼研究到現在
2500天耶
2011年開始
所以也大概9年 8年了
10年
2011年了
今年2020年快結束了
10年來
對
我做區間獲利前15名
這個我們把它遮起來
10年來耶
對 10年來
這檔股票維生
對
它的區間獲利最厲害的15家
這個要遮起來
這不能外洩
不能外泄
他是我大哥
国家大哥
因为我的钱都要靠他
真的 中南部人你真的不要惹
对 他买我就跟着买
他卖我就跟着卖
我都靠他赚钱
他是我大哥
但是我不能泄露他是谁
但是这边就有讲
他的分点名字都有陆港
陆港台北新台
你看这是什么自由的
这个都在台中
中部人都大赚
你看第一名赚多少
六万万就是六亿
六亿
第一名專留意
然後區間虧損前15名的
這就可以通通列出來了
通通列出來了 外國人
對 肉腳 八國聯軍
你看這個摩根大通
香港人 台灣會立
以前叫東方會立
東方會立 對
台灣摩根史丹利 港商野村
大和國泰 八國聯軍
難怪很多今年都說要退出台灣
來一個宰一個 來兩個宰一隊
來八個 宰八個 好
所以地緣分典大勝八國聯軍
對 台灣之光啊
我們做股票研究這個就好了
研究外資 肉腳
肉腳才看外資
可是怎麼樣研究呢 有點難
因為你剛才說台股1700多家
大概200多家有地緣券上
我要怎麼樣找到
我就每天研究籌碼
研究完呢 我就會貼在我的粉絲團
每天我都會貼標題出來
所以你就每天看標題
你大概就可以知道
像8月24號我就寫
這主投買
你還記得主投買嗎
記得啊 主力跟投信都買
主投買 廣民預期漲停
這個是前一天喔
前一天主投買 今天漲停
我有加你粉絲團啦
但是你每次公布完
我都想小哥都已經買好了
我們是前一天研究
前一天研究 隔天驗證
關鍵買 可成維生大漲
地板股景德大廠
地板股我們也有交
地板股也交過了
其實我們都有交
那我們就提早講
我們不是事後論
什麼叫事後論
事後論說這個
只要漲上去我們就看多
只要跌下來我們就看空
這叫事後論
我認識很多這種
我們不是事後論
例如說像維生
維生最近剛好關鍵也在買
哇 這個買得好像很兇的感覺
這關鍵買喔
對
他從這個第一檔開始買
那維生就大漲
他低檔買的時候
我們就會研究
我們就會寫出來
所以這些其實就是剛剛講的
台中 新台中 彰化 陸港
都是那些人
他們都愛買
那股價就容易漲
我們沒有推薦
我們只是告訴你現象
現在現象就是
在他旁邊的那些券商
都有人在大買
然後根據過去十年
小哥累計了十年的歷史經驗
這些關鍵的分點
他們買通常都是區間大賺
對 沒錯
這都是經驗呈現
沒有預測股價
但是剛剛趙華有一個疑問了
那麼多家公司啊
我要怎麼樣一步一步去找出說
這些分點啊
第一是真的有用
第二就是它是地緣又是關鍵
它又真的有賺錢
不好找餒
好 我今天特別教各位
今天是個教學節目
這個收費很貴的課
我特別教給各位
你在外面收多少
都3,800
3,800美元吧
3800有點低 我們都收3800台幣
這個上課是這樣
收3萬你去上完
你覺得沒有收貨
它就是你仇人
對 收3000
你去上課你會笑得很開心
出來呢 欸 我好像看了一場秀
下次還會再來
所以不要收太貴
難怪阿哥上次說有一堂3800的
阿哥好久沒來了
我們都3800而已
SOP來教大家找關鍵分點
好 第一個呢
我們要找高檔大賣分點
高檔大賣啊 就很厲害囉
第二個呢 找低檔大買分點
這也太強了
對 因為有時候高檔大賣
他可能 你看不到他買喔
對 不知道他什麼時候買的啊
他可能就是這個大股東啊
對
他這個在2011年前 他就有股票了
所以你只能看到大賣
那低檔大賣 有的買了之後
他沒有在賣的喔
也是 可能他就可以放到天長地久
對 第三個呢
我們要找尋獲利分點
那這獲利分點呢
就常就是低檔大買
又高檔大賣
這種我們最喜歡
因為他會現身
因為就像你講的
他大賣你找不到他什麼時候買
不過他大買他還沒賣
這種我也參考不到
沒錯 這種獲利分點
就低檔大買高檔大買最喜歡
好
那第四個呢
關鍵分點呢
常常它就是地緣分點
地緣分點
但是我有一個疑問了
像我們內科啊
什麼竹科 公司這麼多
所以我很難講說
在台北買的就跟它有關啊
對不對
我們這樣講
分點呢 台北的最難認
台北大概這個有點參考
是內湖那邊
就內科那裡啊
對 就內湖那邊還可以
你只要看到台北市啊
忠孝東路啊 敦南啊
那個就很難
就是周子片一條街對不對
對啊 那個證券
證券一條街
那個很難找分點
那離開台北市都很好找
對 沒錯
所以剛剛也講了
可能要非台北地區的地緣分點
比較容易界定這樣子
好 四個SOP下來
再來我們該怎麼做
那我們來講地緣大買
什麼叫地緣大買呢
什麼叫大買 對不對
第一個 買超張數喔
它一定要在前五名的地緣分點
前五名 總共有幾名啊
九百多名
九百多名的前五名
那很厲害了
現在全台灣的分點九百多家喔
你要買到兼這檔股票
買超的前五名
那不容易
這是一種搶投胎的能力了
對不對
這要買前五名喔
像那個我們剛剛講維生啊
第一檔你就會看到入港人不是第一名就第二名第二個呢前數名至少出現兩個以上免得很難分辨嘛 對不對
如果前數名到我們這些台北人
那很難 不行 對
我們長期研究啊
我們發現台北人比較肉腳
都被中南部宰著玩的
你知道為什麼嗎
因為台北一堆外資啊
外資就是肉腳
因為外資賺的是期貨那邊的
他希望在那邊犧牲黨
我犧牲沒關係啊
我騎往那邊大賺就好了
而且台北的人口密集
韭菜多
好 所以第三點來了
中南部更準
中南部大買的都很厲害喔
餐狗啊 有錢人
我記得我2008年那時候
有去中南部那時候金融海嘯嗎
就他們那時候有個現象
就中部的高爾夫球場都爆滿
因為不做生意很無聊
可是也不是沒錢就去打高爾夫
對 難不難說有錢人
對啊 中南部就是這種風氣
來吧 介紹一檔中部的給你認識
中部的愛用者
金元 記得是做鍵盤的
做鍵盤的 我們來看一下
這個在低檔的時候主力在幹嘛
主力其實是買買賣賣 沒有什麼很明確
可是是必設置這條線
在這個中軌的中間線下面
所以基本上是在賣方
然後外資大賣
投信大賣
關鍵分點大買
人氣我取
對 股票一定這樣
股票今天成交1萬張
就1萬張買 1萬張賣
那外資投信大賣
到底誰接走了
全部都被他耶
他接走了
他是誰
關鍵分點接走了
好 他誰
待會會跟各位講
好
我們來看一下
那一天發生什麼事
那一天
有個新聞出來
金元列助益股票
二月份美股虧損0.07元
虧錢的公司
對 各位你下次看到這種新聞
股價在低檔
關鍵分點再買
買下去
又發利空
而且這時候又有疫情
對啊
根本就覺得二月就虧了
那後面怎麼辦
利空誰發的 你想想看
利空誰發的
一定是公司派發的啊
對不對
我們這些記者很可憐
公司派 發立工自己偷偷買
外資看到立工好害怕賣掉
高手高高手 外資都是韭菜
散戶也賣啊
散戶看了也怕啊 對
厲害的就是這個關鍵分點
結果呢高檔8月17號 對
現在漲到七十幾塊了
四隔五個月
我們再來看一下8月17號這邊
哈哈哈哈
20塊喔 20塊買
78塊
他利空在這邊耶
對啊
然後8月在這邊
8月多啊 8月多在這裡啊
8月多啊
高檔 股價漲了多少
股價漲了快4倍了
股價漲快4倍了 來吧
好 這個
10檔Q2 EPS創高
法人暗戰
那法人暗戰 法人在幹嘛
法人在買啊
哇 買超第二季 EPS創新高的股票
金元
為什麼二月虧損第二季卻創新高
對
法人在買外資投信大買
這個關鍵就大賣
哎呦
那法人按讚
各位記得以後看到
法人按讚
對
股票高檔
關鍵大賣
對
你就要按賣
你不要按買喔
我跟你講法人按讚嘛
然後關鍵分點是這樣按讚
對
關鍵分點趕快到貨
不趁這時候到貨
我們再回來看
不趁這時候
你看這時候股價高檔你看
拼命到 到貨耶
你看這幾張 2000張耶
然後這邊的話其實外資是大買耶
大買 投信大買
肉腳
肉腳 對
那到底誰在買
被欺負好了
揭露一下 有地緣嗎
揭露一下 來吧
剛剛說要有地緣啊
這裡這裡
叉叉證券北屯分行
那是我大哥
是
我們要保護他
尊敬的北屯大哥
對 這個我講公告出來之後
他搬到南屯怎麼辦
不是台中人
哥哥是大哥
尊敬點
他離那個公司很近
20分鐘
中午出來吃個飯下個單也不為過
有的是住這裡
然後去那邊上班
然後這個回來
最近公司好忙
股價低檔趕快買股票
厲害的分點是這樣
所以這邊也有整理出
他前五下15大的分點對不對
北屯一個台中一個
這兩個就要特別留意它
它有分點叫彈指分點
彈指也在台中啊
也很厲害啊
也很近啊
所以這個金友我們就看這兩個分點
好
但是我要怎麼查到是哪一些
地緣分點在買咧
我要去哪些
有沒有網站啊
或者免費的APP啊
免費的
證交所
哇
政府開的
而且這個是最早出來的
只要是政府開
應該都不好用吧
可是很早出來
你在3點多就可以查了
哦 好 尊敬
對 一般軟體它要大數據統計
撈資料 但要4點半
這個最快 3點多就好
尊敬 莊家
對 這證交所買賣日報表
查詢系統 查到
好 對 很佛心
是的 好 所以來這邊
KeyJing你要查的代號一按
其實它會告訴你今天有哪些券商
是主要在買的券商
再對一下有沒有地緣性
那它又大買
那可能就是關鍵分點了
這很累喔 你可能要按好幾頁
這個可能就是要有Excel的功力
因為很多證交所的網站
台灣是全世界籌碼最幸福的地方
因為我們的證交所都有公佈籌碼
只是你到他的網站
你要自己做表格
資料匯下來之後
你要開始自己去跑
你要的那些條件
所以比較辛苦一點
但是很多券商或是APP
其實幫我們整理好了
對 沒錯
然後不是業配啦
這沒什麼好做業配
沒有 因為這很多家都有
像凱基鎮也有
這不是業配喔
凱基元大都有
凱基哥沒給我們錢
都沒給
這個很多家都有
那你看這可成的
他跟你講我最近買的
我有沒有看到可成台南台南
台南人喔
可成或東門
都台南
台南股價甜不甜
最近股價甜甜價
最近跌了有一段
因為大盤不好
但台南人沒有放棄它
不過可承煙就很撐
很撐喔
就是因為台人買
沒有大碟這樣
就沒有大碟
這個高檔很多都大碟
但可承就沒有
好 那APP也可以查
好
這個很多APP啊
像這一檔
哇 你看大元都在幹嘛
大元都在賣
都在賣就要小心
就是桃園的分點嗎
對啊 大元桃園 中立桃園
這檔是漁城找的
漁城找的
哪一家啊
哪一家
公司在桃園就對了
好 那你要講清楚啊
公司在桃園
我沒有要講出來嗎
我不知道哪一家
不好意思講
所以這邊如果關鍵分點在賣
又在都是桃園的
那就有地緣關係
按示一下
股價低於10塊8.51
又在桃園的公司
是大公司嗎
還好
還好啦
因為他的張數不多
對
大家自己猜
猜對了留言給我們
余晨自己去回
對
好
那我們長期研究籌碼之後
我們就發現勝率就會提高
好
主頭賣 台北哥大跌 關鍵賣
像上銀 上銀最近連續黑K
七根 我從頭報到尾
因為上銀有個分點很厲害
上銀這家公司很厲害
趙華不敢多說
真的 這個分點超厲害的
這分點上市在500多塊大賣
後面股價就崩盤 崩到200多
最近又在300多塊大賣
我就跟了
我大哥 大賣 我當然跟他
去空一些股票企劃
就是以前我們會說啊
坊間有些神人
例如說也算命啦
或摸股師
會在一些鄉間有沒有
像上癮我覺得應該
全台灣最厲害的財務的
製作者應該就在上癮啦
這樣子啊
講得很明顯
關鍵如果賣
我們就要注意了對不對所以每天的標題呢就是我們會事先研究後面驗證所以這是告訴各位長期研究籌碼勝率會我們自己也可以來做一下筆記
就是我今天觀察到什麼樣的狀態
我自己寫下來
不見得要買就先寫
然後隔天隔兩天驗證
你這樣做幾個月之後
你可能對自己就很有信心
對
好的
像最近的這個
台南人又在幹嘛
哇 課程
我們剛剛講中部
現在跟各位講南部
剛剛有講甜甜的啊
我看這個可乘啊
在高檔喔
300多塊的時候
快400塊耶
對
外資買投信買喔
你看喔
你看這一段
外資買投信買喔
結果關鍵分點在幹嘛
大賣啊
大賣
他一天賣1500張耶
對啊 這太扯了啦
對不對
1500張是多少錢啊
300多塊1500張耶
一張三四十萬的股票
一張三十萬
1500張
你剛剛去刷本資多少錢
幾億啊
幾億的錢
幾億的
但是他下來的話
這邊看起來有一些分點
這邊大買
台南人在大買了
對
那這個關鍵分點賣的時候
各位看喔
第一檔的時候
關鍵分點大買
也大買
但他很厲害耶
他這樣其實佈局的
可能快要一年半
對
佈局一年半
沒關係啊
在上面賣一張
底下買兩張
對
那390大賣
你看現在170
買兩張
這一檔真的要聽台南人的
真的很厲害
真的
千萬不要看新聞
好
來看一下新聞
新聞說什麼呢
來吧
2018年7月21號
對
300多塊的時候
今天400塊
是
可曾下半年營運逐漸揚升
股價創近10月新高
對
然後這個你看外資跟投信的大買
嗯
外資投信大買
關鍵大賣
高檔利多
對
結果跌下來之後
這個2019年1月4號
跌到100多塊
是
低檔利空
外資投信大賣
美系外資給他降頻
誰啊
瓶蓋股
強倒眾人推
這麼狠的標啊
可成外資降頻
那外資怎麼賣
外資也真的有賣
所以這次外資是真的不看好
真的不看好
不是為了踹他兩腳買回來
不是
結果全部又被台南人買走了
台南人說太好了
對 太好了
你看這新聞
外資持股跌破五成
可曾再探低點
最近的新聞
9月22號
因為他賣場嘛 對不對
讓人家覺得說他可能競爭力
這個飢渴場可能有點問題
對不對 一個中國公司賣掉了
而且被大陸公司買走了
對 怎麼會這樣
你看這新聞出來
外資大賣
可是當時我們在解讀新聞
其實古語也在嘛
把不賺錢的東西賣掉有什麼不對
很好啊 對
而且之後呢
這個不曉得什麼時候要提列
一提列出來
哇塞 最近EPS爆升了
所以最近呢
我们来看一下给各位看
最近这30天
9月23号前30天
大买的分点你看一下
南部分点
北高雄
元大金华也是
凯基东门
元富台南
凯基台南
你看到公司在这边
最近30天内买超的分点
北高雄厲害喔
北高雄是最進進台南的
就是高雄的北部
沒錯 還有一堆台南分點
都在買可乘
都是外資在到
所以我們之後看看
到底誰獲勝
列入觀察喔
因為現在就是很多的台南人在買可乘
當然你會覺得可乘最近的股價表現好像比較疲弱
所以就是請你觀察他好不好
練習
所以可乘現在
趙懷列入觀察
趙华喜歡台南 也喜歡吃甜的
他們鱔魚炒麵啊 什麼土拖魚跟都是甜的
所以股價甜的時候我們要注意
要注意 要注意
那剛剛提的維生呢
最近呢 我們也發現他在幹嘛
他在買囉
對喔 關鍵分點在大買
對 他也是厲害的喔
我們來看一下高檔他大賣
低檔他大買厲害
所以這低檔大買的時候
他剛好又出現在地板股
哦哟
小哥的鐵粉
對這個地板股
我們這個據我統計
對
勝率最高的股票
叫做地板加地緣
哎呦 地板就夠低了
地緣這時候試貨
地緣又大買
我們叫雙地概念股
雙地概念股
雙地一出來
哇 雙地出現
不是雙低
是雙地概念股
雙低是那個
那個森李博士
我們是雙地概念股
雙地概念股 厲害了
地緣大買
股價又在地板價
甜甜價
後面你看後面大談一段
你還記得年初我們講一檔股票
美利達
有 記不記得
那時候地板股我們就
舉美利達為例
我記得好像彰化人在買
對 原林人
哇 你記性很好
那時候六七十塊
是
你後來美利達多少錢
200多
好好 我懂
我們沒有叫大家買 懂就好
懂就好 我們觀察就好
觀察就好
那這個維生在高檔的時候
2018年4月28號
前年的4月
維生Q1 美股大賺2.4元
超棒啊
一般人看到這個
哇 興奮啊 按下去
對不對 買進
就外資投信跟你一樣買進
關鍵大賣
哇塞
又到貨給外資投信
所以當我們看到
利多利空新聞的時候
如果我們懂得觀察
所謂的地緣券商或關鍵分點
事實上我們可能更容易
看懂這條新聞要幹嘛對不對
沒錯 這個地緣分解太厲害了
好
你看這個外資對砍目標價
2018年10月18號
砍到167塊喔
對
股價夠低了喔
從376塊對砍到167
外資砍目標價
對 股票也砍
是
外資投信大賣
關鍵又大賣
現在我看到這種外資看空的
是不是要興奮一下
興奮一下
應該先撈起來看一下
對 沒錯
這是不是也一種篩選法
只要股票在低檔
看到這新聞
記得傳訊給我
小哥
我真的會傳給你
小哥你會告訴我現在怎麼樣
對 這檔股票怎麼樣
我就告訴你最近誰有在買
因為每天看分點
好
所以大家看到利空
反而要先列入你的自選
就是外資投信大賣
如果關鍵分點大賣
你可能就有雙地概念
雙地概念
像9月23號前30天
錄影播出前30天
最近呢
這個我們發現
陸港人啊 台中人啊 台中人啊
最近有開始在小小的布局
哦 好
所以這個各位呢 看看就好
不是要報牌
陸港的鄉親 台南的鄉親
像我在屏東
屏東的鄉親
應該都有一定的地緣性
屏東最近也有標股
我們等一下把它拿出來檢視看看
好的 就打球的
對 沒錯 屏東有一些
屏東有一些
所以大家要記得
剛剛小哥有講
地緣捐商哪裡比較準
中南部比較準
那我們很久沒有更新
小哥的榮耀班了
小哥今天自投羅網
他要準備了另外一份
非常關鍵的券商分店
是什麼呢
還記得嗎
如果你買的股票
有隔日沖進來亂的時候
你可能會錯砍你手上的股票
那小哥今天會在榮耀班大放送
告訴你
誰是最關鍵的隔日沖券商
所以想要知道的話
記得來訂閱我們的榮耀班
好 今天的歌有仇必報
在趙華的生綠社的衣服下呢
還是有投資的機會怎麼講
關鍵分點永遠都比你早知道
像今天大跌
或是你看到外資大賣
外資降評投信大賣
但是地緣券商卻在大買的時候
你真的不要反而悲觀
你這時候要去撿好不好
那小哥有講雙地概念股
地板股 地緣券商
這種股票最有搞頭
那希望今天能夠讓你學到滿滿的知識喔
我們下禮拜再見了
掰掰